yeah hello and welcome to this
announcement video yeah listen and good
announcement video to make because it's
something new I'm starting today I will
do a double been tablet session on chess
24 which does that mean and yeah we
start out at 6pm Central Europe in time
with the German language been tablets in
deutsch defense please yeah so it's a
German language the chat will be German
language and I'm also going to do it in
German so that's the start of it it's 19
minutes and then at eight in the evening
central european time two hours later
basically I'm just taking a small break
after the German session I'm going to do
the same thing in English so 90 minutes
of benja bits in English on chest when
you form you can both get to both those
some events on the chest 24 website it's
also YouTube stream but it makes sense
to to watch it on the chest 24 5 because
the chat on chest 24 is used for them
for this event it's not the chat on
youtube so you can watch it on just 24 I
think even without having an account but
if you want to participate in the chat
you need a chest 24 account which is
some free you don't need to be premium
to chat so you need to be premium to
play me but you can chatter also with a
basic non premium account so it's a
double feature based ok two 90-minute
shows 90 minutes in German 90 minutes in
English and this is also going to be a
weekly feature for the next four weeks
the German language stream ISM is a test
run let's see how many viewers it have
so if you are yeah if you are fewer in
the German want to watch on wants to
watch anyway even though you don't speak
any German make sure to tune in it's
going to be a VI will be great if we can
make a regular feature out of this I
like to do some German content so thanks
for watching the announcement video bye
bye